on va pas tout de suite avait retranché
dans l'émission bertrand charme au
matcha mauroy qui revient c'est parti
jamais il a commis une erreur historique
il faut qu'il revienne intervient alors
non
bertrand tu vas être avec nous dans un
instant mon chéri merci des flots exil
n'a pas changé en termes de conducteurs
et d'organisation et ça ça fait plaisir
commence à rater la merci mon bertron
d'être là mon chéri je suis vraiment
très très heureux de te voir
alors chaque soir tu vas nous donner la
météo la météo tout ce qui est minimale
maximale et tout le toutim
alors mon chéri je suis très content de
te vois pas ce que l'on en parle et
alors tu vas venir nous rejoindre sur le
plateau mais déjà je trouve magnifique
merci mais vraiment il est pas bon
franchement mon bertrand est ce que vous
êtes content du retour de bertrand
délais aux dires d'un instant vous à lui
dire devant lui puisqu'il va venir nous
rejoindre alors bertrand tu es de retour
aujourd'hui
oui tu sais que tu t'es peut-être une
question de posée oui non mais a donc là
on est parti sur la météo est d'accord
donc c'est carrément parce qu'on m'a
vraiment fait ce côté météo mettront la
musique quand même là les ont pas râler
on tourne la météo horaires
c'est
[Applaudissements]
bertrand maintenant du plant meta de
pain ben oui à paris quoi je suis à
paris la voyez la nuit entre chien et
loup
oui moi je suis chroniqueur et animateur
de télévision sur la télévision
numérique terrestre la tnt comme on dit
est donc désormais en charge de la météo
tout ce qui est soleil pluie anticyclone
dépression nerveuse et tutti quanti qu
avant de commencer une petite question
qui me taraude cyril la chaîne là sur
laquelle on est en train d'officialiser
la c8 où elle appartient bien au groupe
canal alors on est plus que jamais une
chaîne du groupe canal+ je voudrais te
le dire mon bertrand pourquoi tu me
demande ça non comme ça la vérité le
grand beau grand bâton canal n'est pas
hyper fan de bertrand chamerois
d'aujourd'hui ou ne l'est pas dans la
direction de canal+ n'est pas hyper fan
de bertrand ne vous dis pas donc c'est
sûr qu'il y aura pas dans le groupe
canal non mais ça arrive ça se travaille
[Applaudissements]
vraiment un patron d'une petite question
moi même j'ai repris excuse moi mais on
est bien d'accord je pouvais la question
chroniqueur ici jeff on essaie quoi
l'émission mpmp sais bien que ces merdes
touche pas à mon poste l'émission là oui
pourquoi je dis ça parce que je
considère que ça n'aurait pas de sens
on a fait le tour de la boucle est
retourné dans tpm peu à part pour faire
un clin d'oeil vous lu ça mais je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez quoi
quoique est cela qu est-ce qu là on la
retourne
voilà c'est fait mais les versions wii
bonbons bertrand d'amour est ce que tu
peux douter la météo quand même avec
plaisir demain matin le temps sera
pluvieux dans le
le en principe le kart les cartes ce
serait génial et a dû plaît à l'appeler
dans le nord dans le quart sud ouest une
météo que je qualifierais
personnellement de mossad à l'hiver mais
tu es parti d'ailleurs dû globalement on
est sur du beau temps du côté des
températures des valeurs de saison
comprises entre 10 la minimale mulhouse
montélimar la maximale sera pour
perpignan avec 19 degrés l'après midi
une flèche rouge attaquera marseille où
il va on est sur les gas salut je me dis
que c'est le vent autant pour moi est
une première vous l'avez vu bref une
france à deux vitesses du gris du jeune
en fonction de votre lieu dit
d'habitation 20 degrés à lille 26 à nice
30 à toulouse et 25
ça replonge dans l'ain hadja d'offres
nous serons le mardi 4 septembre et nous
fêterons les rosalies bonne fête à tous
les fans de carlos don
[Applaudissements]
hier trois caméras qui avait tout fait